[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing both wizard kind
and humankind with the former of course
being a subset
of the latter first we'll be taking a
look at the history of humankind
and the first instances of witches and
wizards and
then we will be taking a look at the
physiological differences between a
regular human
and a magical being while the original
ancestors of humans were thought to have
first existed
about six million years ago the more
modern form of humans
the ones that we're accustomed to have
only been around for two hundred
thousand years or so
the first link to humanity began with a
primate group
called ardipithecus a group based out of
africa
that were revolutionary in that they
were the first group to begin the path
of walking upright
as we do now the adipithecus group
originated
over 6 million years ago and this group
was of particular importance to the
development of humanity
as their ability to walk upright allowed
for free use of the hands
with their hands free it allowed
pre-humans to develop further
and begin to focus on using their hands
for other purposes
the next group of pre-humans that rose
to prominence were the australopithecus
group
which are thought to have first existed
sometime between two
and four million years ago the
australopithecus were notable
in that in addition to walking they were
also able to climb
trees next came the paranthropus thought
to have first existed sometime between
two and
three million years ago which can be
most notably distinguished by
its enlarged teeth which allowed for a
broader diet
as you can see as time passed these
pre-humans developed more and more of
the traits that we see
in more modern day humans however it
wasn't until just over two million years
ago
that the homo group the group which
contains our own species
homo sapiens first arose the homo group
can be most notably distinguished from
the other groups by their bigger brains
tool-making and ability to expand their
territory
reaching far beyond the confines of
africa homo sapiens
which we are didn't pop up until 200 000
years ago
and were particularly resilient in that
they were able to survive and thrive
despite climate change over the course
of the last 200
000 years humans have continued to
develop evolve
and adapt and i think that wizardkind
which is of course a subset of humankind
and not an entirely different species
altogether
is just another one of these natural
developments achieving
in some ways a newer and more advanced
form of humanity
but when did wizard kind enter the mix
at what point in history did witches and
wizards
first come to prominence or show signs
of life unfortunately
in the harry potter universe at least
the origins of wizard kind
are known or undefined however we do
have some information about the first
witches and wizards
to have appeared in certain parts of the
world the first known member of wizard
kind to exist in europe
was a witch named cliana who first
presided there sometime
in the middle ages she was an animagus
with the ability to turn into a sea bird
and she actually has her own chocolate
frog card while the middle ages were a
long long time ago
the period between the 5th and 15th
century i would have still expected the
first member of european wizard kind
to have popped up much sooner however
while clientner
was the first to appear in europe there
is one known wizard
that lived much sooner than her in
another part of the world
the first known wizard across all
continents was a wizard by the name
of yayamanek who hailed from egypt as
far back as 2600
bc there is little to no information
available
on yayamanek other than where he was
from and the period in which he lived
but i do wonder if wizard kind went back
further than that
or if he was truly the first the origins
of magic are still unclear to this day
no one knows whether the inception of
wizard kind was born from humans
randomly discovering their magical
abilities
or if it was created in some form by way
of pact
ritual or potion i find the first theory
more intriguing
however as it aligns with the concept of
muggleborns and how they would first
develop their magical abilities
so the first known magical being didn't
appear until 2600 bc
however members of wizard kind are of
course a kind of
subspecies of human meaning they possess
many of the same
physical characteristics however in
subtle perhaps non-visual ways
they also differ physiologically to some
extent one of the largest ways that
wizard kind differs from humankind
is life expectancy according to a figure
reported by the ministry of divine
health
the average wizarding life expectancy
was reported
at an average of 137 and three-quarter
years old
whether that's down to purely their
physiology is up for us to decide
but they do live considerably longer
than their human counterparts
if they live to 137 and three-quarter
years old on average
this means that members of wizard kind
live for 57 percent longer than members
of humankind who cap out at 79.
i suspect that one of the largest
reasons for this is a subtle difference
in their physiology
that renders them less susceptible to
common diseases illnesses
and sicknesses witches from wizards also
have access to better medicines
and medical remedies this means that in
addition to their already superior
physiology
they're more effectively able to treat a
wide variety of illnesses and conditions
wizarding medicine is particularly
advanced and where a human may suffer
from a potentially fatal bone break
their wizard counterparts would be able
to take advantage of a potion like
skelegro
which either men's broken bones or
regrows them entirely
a broken bone can be fixed in one night
where a human may require a cast along
with months of physical therapy
this is just a prime example of how much
more advanced wizarding medicine is
and one reason why they may be able to
live for so much longer than their human
counterparts
unsurprisingly witches and wizards also
differ from humans
in the way they might react to being
attacked by a magical creature
however one thing that needs to be
addressed is that just as wizard kind is
a subset of humankind
there are also subsets of wizardkind
itself witches and wizards that are born
with unique traits or abilities
uncommon to the majority there are quite
a few subspecies or
subtypes of wizards let's take a look
the first
subtype of wizard kind sears witches and
wizards who are born with the ability to
see
or predict future events utilizing
objects like crystal balls and tarot
cards
sears are able to further tap into their
abilities and gain additional
insights into the events of the future
the next subtype of wizard kind
metamorph magai witches and wizards who
are born with the ability to change
their physical appearance
at will among other physical attributes
metamorph magi
are able to change their noses eyes hair
color and more
the next subtype of wizard kind is
witches and wizards who are born with
the ability to speak
parcel tongue these members of wizard
kind are known as parcel mouths
and the ability is thought to be
hereditary trait passed on
through descendants of hogwarts founder
salazar slytherin
the next subtype of wizard kind are
maledictuses
witches who are born carrying a blood
curse that leads to their eventual and
inevitable transformation
into some sort of beast the maledictus
curse
is exclusive to women and the most
notable example of this
is nagini voldemort's trusty sidekick
that starts off as a quiet
gentle woman and slowly turns into a
giant snake over the course of her life
regardless of when the family was first
cursed once in the bloodline
the maledictus curse will continue to
persist and is passed on from generation
to generation
by mother to daughter the final subtype
of wizard kind
a half vila witches who have one wizard
parent
and one velar parent vela are semi-human
magical beings
who in their regular form are beautiful
women with white cold hair
and glowing skin however when angry the
form of avila changes
dramatically as their faces begin to
elongate
into sharp cruel beaked bird heads with
long scaly wings that burst from their
shoulders the traits of avila are
thought to be hereditary
which is why if they have a daughter
with a wizard the daughter will often
inherit the beauty
charm and seduction of their velar
parent though the aforementioned
subtypes of wizard kind
paint a good picture of the types of
witches and wizards that can exist
as a result of hereditary born traits
it's also worth mentioning
that there are also many witches and
wizards that have been able to
dramatically change their appearance
abilities etc through the use of magic
and
learned traits a few examples of these
witches and wizards
include animegai who garner the ability
to transform into some kind of animal
legitimates who gain the ability to read
minds and
even obscurials witches and wizards who
due to being raised in an environment
where their magic is viewed negatively
develop an obscurus a dark parasitic
force
that is the result of their magic being
suppressed and tainted
by negative emotion and that's it for
this video it turns out the average
member of wizard kind isn't all that
different
from the average member of humankind
what did you guys learn in this video
what surprised you let me know down in
the comment section below
until next time you're a wizard harry
you